was there a point where you thought you
would just be a songwriter because
sometimes with comedians right there's
you do comedy and then sometimes you're
like oh I'm just going to be a writer
and I'm a Wright for like a late night
show or like a Fallon or like which you
were just on or like uh you know or I'm
gonna write for a comedian yeah but I
don't know if the dream ever goes away
to just do comedy but sometimes life
gets in the way you'll get a family or
something I didn't want to have to
choose I was like I can do both I'm
gonna be a songwriter I'm gonna be an
artist I'm gonna do it all but I had
somebody who was who I was working with
at the time who made me believe you
can't be both he was like really you
gotta choose are you a songwriter are
you an artist and I'm like I'm both he's
like no no but you gotta like you gotta
really and I'm like no
look around at some of the most
successful artists I mean decades and
deca for decades you know
they write their own stuff and they sing
their own stuff and it doesn't mean that
I'm opposed to you know cutting outside
songs at the end of the day like I said
the best idea and the best song wins
um
but you can do both
look at Morgan look at Hardy look at
look at all the guys and uh Ernest he
used to pitch for Lipscomb that's what
I'm saying like
you can do it you shouldn't being
creative
you shouldn't be scared to step outside
of the box and in my opinion that's not
even really stepping outside of the box
it's just singing the stuff that you
wrote yeah
and he was going to sing it better than
you he was so wrong that really seems to
yeah that amps you up I'm ready to fight
dude I thought yeah you can beat the
[__] out of me if you want I've been I
mean by women I might
gonna put it on on the camera we're
gonna do it afterwards
other people want look well I'll open a
Bible eat and beat the damn devil out of
them that's gonna be hard to do that's
gonna take a few Bibles yeah yeah we're
gonna give man a little bible too we're
gonna beat the [__] out of you sometimes
it's gonna take you a little longer than
some folks I mean I moved to this town
and people were passing me up left and
right getting publishing deals getting
record deals and
at the end of the day sometimes slow and
steady you know is better and I feel
like I've been trying to do Brick by
Brick just one thing at a time because I
want longevity I don't want to just be a
flash in the pan and I'm not I'm not
doing that so you couldn't be I don't
think
um
I don't see how it would even be
possible and it's funny because if I
listen to Heart Like a truck right but
you're 24 years old I it's not it I
don't believe that yep no I've been
through some stuff
yep and I'm proud of it it's been hard I
mean there's definitely times where I
wish it wouldn't have been that way I
mean
I mean even it's weird because like I
I'm experiencing like really great
things with my career right now even
when I was filming Yellowstone I was
going through like we were losing my
daddy
um he ended up Surviving but like he
spent two months in ICU and I was having
to actually a few of those scenes right
there
um I would go over to the corner and cry
and then come back and then shoot it
again and
it just seems sometimes I'm like man
am I supposed to go through these things
so I can be more relatable to people and
and be more understanding and be able to
write the kind of music that people are
really gonna connect to and listen to
and that's kind of what I chalk it up to
sometimes because I mean life ain't easy
yeah it is what it is you just gotta
keep rolling yeah and sometimes it's
like I don't know I feel like sometimes
like God has a way of reaching people
right and not to make it religious or
anything but it's like sometimes you're
just part of that way that's right you
know and it's not even
yet you have talents and stuff but it's
like sometimes some things they're so
especially with music it's like man this
thing is and so many people have written
and you know there's other people
playing and it's like really to make
this thing it's like it takes a a
village it does take a village it's nice
to feel like I'm finally able to like
I'm in a position where I could help
somebody else because I've had so many
people help me along the way it just
that it feels good to be able to do that
just even inviting them on on the road
you know my tour is completely sold out
yeah we're even moving to some bigger
venue so it's exciting stuff considering
I mean last year looked different I'm
not gonna lie it's crazy really yeah I
mean I played
Yeah March of last year in Tuscaloosa
um we had had a hit with things a man
ought to know and never say never what
Cole Swindell was
just it was killing it at that time too
AC like there were so many things that
we had done but I still could barely
sell a ticket wow I sold like was it 100
or like 91 tickets or something like
that
and a lot of people there were family
and it was like where like where is this
not connecting you know like I feel like
we we won some awards we got some number
ones but still at that time I was pretty
faceless I think that's what happens
with a lot of artists so explain that to
me when you say faceless because this
isn't yeah I think a lot of people know
songs on the radio I think during that
time if you would have asked anybody who
listens to country music like you know
that song things a man ought to know
they all would have said yes but they
did not
know me
um and that's where the disconnect is
and I think that's really where
Yellowstone has been
so beneficial because
you know they see your name up on the
screen and and stuff and then they
finally just like see your face and
they're like oh okay and then I have to
see it a million other times for it to
really really connect I think you've got
everybody's attention now I don't know
how you could ever get rid of it I mean
once I heard your voice I don't think I
could ever thank you man I could just
it's in my ears forever thank you you
know it is very powerful that's cool bro
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one